[Musik]
guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
live mehr mut hat der chef der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung andreas
gassen am wochenende gefordert er will
einen freedom day für deutschland also
ein stichtag an dem alle beschränkungen
aufgehoben werden es geht ja nicht nur
darum dass man den menschen weil auch
ein einen ausstieg aus zeichen muss es
gibt ja auch und das hat jeder
feststellen können mehrfache diskussion
ob es überhaupt eine
verfassungsrechtliche legitimation gibt
verpflichtende maßnahmen bei vorliegen
eines empfanges weiter fortzuführen das
kann ich gar kein jurist es geht ja auch
und das ist ganz wichtig da mal
zuzuhören ich habe gesagt die
verpflichtenden maßen von staatswegen
müssen eingeschränkt werden deshalb
würde ich trotzdem jeden der sich nicht
impfen lassen will dringend empfehlen
darüber hinaus sich auch individuell zu
schützen es geht aber um die
verpflichtende maßnahmen für alle
das klingt erstmal ganz wunderbar und
irgendwie wünschen wir uns das ja auch
wirklich schon seit langem aber sind wir
in deutschland schon so weit darüber
wollen wir sprechen mit dem virologen
doktor martin stürmer und doktor gregor
paul er arbeitet auf der isolierstation
am klinikum stuttgart und wird uns
erzählen wie die situation in den
krankenhäusern zur zeit ist wir sind
gespannt auf ihre kommentare und ihre
meinungen diese in die kommentarspalte
einschreiben können oder eben auf die
adresse schicken die sie hier unten
gerade eingeblendet sehen lassen sie uns
vorher vielleicht einen blick auf die
länder warfen die diesen freedom day im
prinzip schon hatten das wäre zum
beispiel in dänemark da sind die letzten
maßnahmen vor zehn tagen aufgehoben
worden jeder darf wieder in bars und
clubs oder großveranstaltungen besuchen
der nachweis geimpft genesen oder
getestet ist nicht mehr nötig
ja und auch die engländer haben bereits
ihren freedom day gefeiert seit mitte
juli sind masken und abstand halten an
den meisten orten freiwillig man feiert
dort wieder bis in die morgenstunden
es gibt keine beschränkungen mehr für
partys theater oder kinos
ja wir bleiben jetzt erstmal auf der
insel und sprechen mit unserem
korrespondenten andreas stamm hallo
andreas wie hat sich das leben auf der
insel verändert seit diesem freedom day
am 19 juli
andreas du kannst mich glaube ich noch
nicht hören das hat sich natürlich nicht
schlagartig geändert man hat diese
bilder gesehen eben von denen von den
feiernden jungen menschen in den clubs
das war sozusagen
andrea sprich weiter wie ein löwe schon
ich konnte ich hören aber du mich nicht
doch ich werde ich jetzt auch mit hat
sie frage einfach weiter beantworten wir
haben eine kleine zeitverzögerung
ok sorry sorry das technische probleme
wunderbar ja so ungefähr
ungefähr so wie dieses technischen
problemen hat sich auch dieser film day
gestaltet es ging so ein bisschen
stottere ich los da hat man jetzt diese
party people gesehen in dem clip das war
natürlich eine erste reaktion aber dann
haben doch viele sehr viel vorsicht
walten lassen die masken blieben
weitestgehend an es war also überhaupt
nichts von freedom day so richtig zu
spüren man hat erst mal abgewartet denn
die zahlen waren ja enorm hoch zu diesem
zeitpunkt die neue infektionszahlen und
da war es eher so einen tröpfchen für
tröpfchen für tröpfchen und mittlerweile
sieht das ganz anders aus mittlerweile
selbst wenn man in die u-bahn geht in
die die busse steigt hier in london wo
eigentlich immer noch masken pflicht
gilt zumindest das hat der betreiber der
transportunternehmen eben bestimmt da
halten sich die leute nicht mal dran
weil es natürlich auch unglaublich
schwer ist das polizeilich jetzt zu
verfolgen weil es ja offiziell diese
pflicht zum beispiel nicht mehr gibt und
andreas sag mal wie hat sich das jetzt
auf das infektionsgeschehen ausgewirkt
ganz so was zu den aktuellen zahlen
sagen
ja man kann das sehr genau hier
verfolgen es gibt da grafiken zum 7
tagesgeschehen und wenn man da mal guckt
mitte juli gegen die korona zahlen
zunächst zurück und das war total
unerwartet denn man hat da eigentlich da
mit einem anstieg gerechnet selbst die
wissenschaftlichen berater der regierung
die saßen hier im fernsehen und sagte
vielleicht haben wir 200.000 neue fälle
täglich wir wir sind wirklich besorgt
und dann gingen die zahlen zurück und
jeder dachte ja was denn jetzt und dann
gehen die sinnsuche los oder die suche
nach den gründen und es war sehr
schwierig viele sagten okay die meisten
leute sind weiter sehr vorsichtig
gewesen die wm die em die fußball-em war
zu ende das muss man auch sagen das
führte dann dazu dass das einfach diese
großen treffen in pubs und diese feiern
nicht mehr stattfanden die schulen haben
sich nicht mehr getroffen sind in die
sommerferien gegangen und es gab es eine
reihe von gründen aber am ende des tages
war man sehr überrascht dass die
neuinfektionen zurückgehen aber dann
gingen sie wieder hoch und steigen jetzt
so konstant auf einem plateau von 30.000
fällen im 7 tagesschnitt das ist eine
instanz von 350 das ist verdammt hoch im
vergleich zu deutschland und auch bei
den einweisungen ins krankenhaus an den
schweren verläufen ist genau dasselbe
passiert aber es geht weiter hoch und in
sieben tagen schnitt geht jeden tag 900
bis 1000 menschen hier ins krankenhaus
mit corona und auch 150 menschen sterben
jeden tag hier im schnitt das heißt das
ist leben mit corona dass es den preis
den man erst mal dafür zu zahlen bereit
ist zumindest ihr in großbritannien die
britische regierung genau das wäre jetzt
meine frage gewesen leben die menschen
jetzt einfach mit diesen hohen zahlen
nimmt man das jetzt einfach in kauf und
ist corona überhaupt noch so ein großes
thema wie bei uns in deutschland
also ich glaube hier teilt sich eben die
bevölkerung für die regierung ist es
weiterhin natürlich ein thema aber man
sagt eben okay das ist das was wir
bereit sind hinzunehmen dafür dass die
wirtschaft lieder wieder läuft dass man
hier wieder ungefähr so leben kann wie
vor der pandemie was auch unglaublich
wichtig war den großbritannien hat ja
einen der tiefsten abstürze seiner
wirtschaft hingelegt liegt ein bisschen
an der struktur sehr viel
dienstleistungen hier die natürlich in
der pandemie in einem blog tor völlig
flach vielen und die menschen ja gut
manche sind weiterhin mit horror
gestraft vor allen die dieses gefühl
haben dass sie sich jetzt eigentlich
frei draußen gar nicht bewegen können
und die die sagen ja mir passiert eh
nicht ich bin zum beispiel auch geimpft
ich bin geimpft und genesen die können
das leben wieder in vollen zügen
genießen und natürlich es wurde auch
weiter weiter fleißig geimpft und die
impfquote ist weiter weiter gestiegen
und insofern gibt es da anlass für
optimismus aber es gibt auch viele die
sich große sorgen machen und jetzt kommt
der herbst und dann kommt der winter das
hatten wir alles schon mal wie will man
in england verhindern dass diese zahlen
dann wieder völlig explodieren
also nachdem man beim letzten mal so
daneben lag mit der projektion dass das
nach dem freedom der irgendwie
exorbitant anschlag ist man vorsichtiger
aber die modellierer die oft richtig
gelegen haben bei dieser pandemie das
muss man auch sagen die modellierer der
regierung des wissenschaftlichen
beratergremiums die sagen wenn es 8000
täglichen einweisungen in krankenhäuser
gibt im winter dann dürfte würde uns das
auch nicht überraschen das ist eine
maximale zahl dass das würde dann das
gesundheitssystem hier überlasten und
insofern hat man natürlich einen plan b
wenn man man weiß man darf corona als
gegner sage ich jetzt mal nicht
unterschätzen die delta variante ist
hoch ansteckend die zahlen sind
weiterhin hoch jetzt gehen alle wieder
rein die schulen haben jetzt wirklich
flächendeckend wieder offen und man
macht sich sorgen dass dann zahlen
zustande kommen vielleicht noch eine
grippewelle obendrauf hier wird auch
schon fleißig gegen grippe geimpft und
dass diese faktoren eben wirklich zu
einem zusammenbruch des
gesundheitssystems führen können das ist
das horrorszenario keine frage der plan
b wäre eben wieder masken pflicht
wiederum arbeiten von zu hause also
nicht ins office gehen und auch
vielleicht
passports für wechsel menschen also dass
man einfach nicht in events rein kanone
geimpft zu sein das will man dann ein
für das wäre dann wieder zwangsmaßnahmen
und natürlich gibt es auch einen plan c
damit offiziell nicht darüber gesprochen
aber das wäre natürlich lockt downs wenn
es wirklich so schlimm kommt aber man
hat gelernt corona ist da wirklich im
wahrsten sinn des wortes unberechenbar
andreas letzte frage an dich boris
johnson hatte aber trotzdem im sommer
gesagt dass dieser weg aus dem lot down
unumkehrbar ist was schätzt du wird es
dabei bleiben
im endeffekt bestimmt stimmen dass die
zahlen also wie gesagt er hat diesen
winter plan vorgestellt der sich eben in
den teil glieder dass davon auch nicht
vergessen weiter wie bisher impfen
impfen impfen das heißt booster shops
für alle über 50 für alle die in
krankenhäusern arbeiten also direkt in
kontakt kommen die ältesten die ja meist
gefährdeten und auch impfen für zwölf-
bis 15-jährige das war hier lange
umstritten um sozusagen die impfquote
noch weiter nach oben zu treiben um
geschützt zu sein aber wenn das versagt
wenn die zahlen steigen wenn das
gesundheitssystem droht
zusammenzubrechen wie im vergangenen
winter im januar dann auf den höhepunkt
wo wir 2000 tote fast täglich hatten
dann wird es hier auch wieder
zwangsmaßnahmen geben und dann würde es
hier auch wieder ein log drangeben
benötigt das da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher aber das sind eben die
horrorszenarien und man ist sich
wirklich nicht sicher wie sich corona
hier entwickelt es ist ein spiel auf
zeit 1 mit hohem risiko denn das ist das
land großbritannien das sich hohe
instanzen und fast alle freiheiten
erlaubt
dank andreas stamm für deine schilderung
wie es euch nach dem freedom day in
england ergangen ist wir hatten jetzt
leider diese zeitverzögerung das war ein
bisschen schade aber warum sich trotzdem
sehr gut hören können vielen dank
tja das ist die situation in
großbritannien und jetzt wollen wir nach
deutschland und wollen mit doktor martin
stürmer sprechen guten abend herr
stimme wenn sie diese diese bilder sehen
von diesen vielen menschen die sich in
den armen liegen ohne maske und ohne
abstand wie geht es ihnen damit
auf der einen seite ist das natürlich so
ein schönes gefühl dass man denkt das
möchten wir alle gerne mal wieder haben
auf der anderen seite sich das absolute
kritisch weil wir haben ja die zahlen
jetzt aus england gehört das als erfolg
zu feiern das finde ich schon sehr
grenzwertig weil man natürlich ein
extrem hohe infektions quote in kauf
nimmt infektion auch gerade bei vielen
jüngeren menschen in kauf nimmt die wir
noch gar nicht impfen können und von
denen wir auch gar nicht wissen wie sich
das ganze letztendlich auf dauer
auswirken wird im körper bei all diesen
ganzen unbekannten bin ich eigentlich
das gegenteil ich möchte infektionen
weiterhin vermeiden und deswegen kommt
für mich so was eigentlich für
deutschland gar nicht in frage
er stimme wir schauen uns mal kurz die
aktuellen zahlen für deutschland an wir
schauen mal auf die impfrate geimpft
waren bis zum wochenende mit mindestens
einer impfdosis 67 2 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung und vollständig
geimpft sind jetzt
63,1 prozent schauen wir auf die neue
infektion da zeigt die linie die zahl
der neuinfektionen im sieben tage
schnitt und fall zum beispiel am
wochenende grundsätzlich weniger fälle
gemeldet werden bildet das dann den
aktuellen trend ja besser ab nachdem die
zahlen seit juli stetig angestiegen sind
sinken die neuinfektionen derzeit wieder
leicht hat man gesehen und hier die
hospitalisierung rate also die zahl der
kogit patienten pro 100000 einwohner die
innerhalb einer woche in ein krankenhaus
eingewiesen wurden die lack jetzt
zuletzt bei 1,65 und der bisherige
höchstwert das war an weihnachten der
lag bei knapp 16
wie würden sie uns diese zahlen
einschätzen was bedeuten die im moment
wo stehen wir
ja also zum einen sind wir in der
vierten welle die das abflachen der co2
das leichte sinken ist noch lange kein
entspannungssignal das wird durch diese
vierte welle durch sind das ist eine
kurze verschnaufpause
und jetzt werden ja die tage auch schon
wieder deutlich kürzer ehrlichkeit wird
kürzer die temperaturen gehen deutlich
nach unten über kurz oder lang werden
die zahlen auch wieder steigen und fahrt
aufnehmen die hospitalisierung gut das
wissen wir ja auch dass durch das viele
impfen letztendlich deutlich weniger
menschen schwer krank werden und auch
ganz versterben das ist eine logische
konsequenz war auch für mehr hat die
risikogruppen primär geimpft haben abend
nichtsdestotrotz und ich denke das
werden wir auch später einfach in den
bericht hören außerdem kollegen aus
stuttgart das auf den intensivstationen
auch vermehrt jetzt die unsere menschen
aufschlagen und wenn wir nicht gehörig
aufpassen und die welle durch laufen
lassen weil wir zu locker sind was den
infektionsschutz angeht dann bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher dass auch den
intensivstationen deutlich mehr los sein
wird in den nächsten monaten
andreas gassen hat er jetzt davon
gesprochen dass wir uns mehr trauen
sollen in deutschland könnte es könnte
man das jetzt mit diesen zahlen wagen
oder ist es diese viel beschworene
german angst die uns da zurückschrecken
lässt
nein ich denke nicht dass wir uns das
jetzt trauen sollten ich bin auch dafür
irgendwann zur normalität zurückzukehren
das auch nicht erst in fünf oder zehn
jahren sondern möglichst bald aber das
kann ich dann wenn ich wirklich allen in
deutschland ein dem stoff anbieten kann
und das ist ja zurzeit eben nicht der
fall für die unter zwölfjährigen gibt es
diesen impfstoff ab einfach nicht und
dementsprechend kann ich jetzt auch mal
dass mit meinem gewissen nicht
vereinbaren solche solche dinge zu
proklamieren
werden in einer ähnlichen situation wie
großbritannien wenn man nach dänemark
schaut das ja gerne auch als beispiel
benutzt wird dass die impfquote deutlich
höher dort fallen die zahlen weiterhin
aber da sind wir ja auch noch nicht so
weit fortgeschritten dass wir
möglicherweise umkehr der der zahlen
durch ebendiesen freedom day sehen aber
letztendlich wenn wir überhaupt über
sowas reden dann meiner meinung nach
wenn wir wirklich impfstoff für alle
haben
gesundheitsminister sparen hat gesagt
dass das jetzt eine pandemie die
umkämpften wird und sie es ja eben auch
schon angesprochen dass es eben für die
unter zwölfjährigen noch keinen
impfstoff gibt
wie können wir diese bevölkerungsgruppe
jetzt diesen herbst winter schützen
ja das ist ganz berechtigte frage wenn
ich mir die maßnahmen an schulen und
kindergärten angucke wird da nicht
wirklich intensiv viel getan wenn ich
mir die maßnahmen angucke die jetzt
aktuell getroffen werden wir sind weg
von der inzidenz auf die
hospitalisierung rate eine zahl mit der
man herzlich wenig aktuell anfangen kann
und auch anfängt wir lassen
infektionsgeschehen umgehen dazu wir
können es im prinzip eigentlich nur
dadurch vermeiden dass sich sehr viele
erwachsene impfen lassen als schutz für
die kleinen kinder und jugendlichen
unter zwölf jahren auch da sind wir im
stocken also im augenblick aber keine
wirklich gute idee im herbst und winter
dort in dieser altersgruppe sehr viele
infektionen zu vermeiden
es gibt gar der bei uns im chat eine
diskussion über masken die schweiz
gerade ein bisschen ab von dem worüber
wir gerade besprochen haben ich würde
aber trotzdem ansprechen denn die frage
ist ob stoffmasken wirklich weniger
sicher sind als op masken und die andere
frage ist ob op masken überhaupt noch
schützen wenn man sie zwei wochen lang
trägt das ist die frage vielleicht
können sie da kurz unseren userinnen und
usern was dazu sagen
ja es ist natürlich so dass die
schutzwirkung das sind ja eigentlich die
optimisten sind wegwerfe einmal artikel
wegwerfartikel einmal benutzen und weckt
damit in den mülleimer natürlich die
schutzwirkung mit der zeit ab und
letztendlich ist das problem mit den
stoffmasken so dass die oft nicht
optimal sitzen und abschließen und
letztendlich auch nicht in der lage sind
die aero sohle einwandfrei abzuhalten
dementsprechend ist es natürlich
weiterhin so der mosel übertragung kann
ich am besten dadurch vermeiden dass ich
eine zwei maske optimal trage oder
zumindest eine auf europa maske optimal
trage das also gut sitzt und natürlich
zusehen dass ich die dinger nicht nicht
wochenlang trage weil dann verlieren sie
über die zeit natürlich auch über
schutzwirkung
die politik hat ja gesagt wir schauen
jetzt mehr auf die hospitalisierung
quote und wir haben es gerade gesehen da
liegt die inzidenz aktuell bei
1,65 und für den laien ist das eine
wirklich sehr abstrakte zahl deshalb
wollen wir die situation in den
krankenhäusern ein bisschen klassischer
machen und deshalb möchte ich jetzt
gerne mit doktor gregor paul sprechen
und ihn in die runde dazu holen er
arbeitet auf der isolierstation am
klinikum stuttgart und ist auch im
pandemie starb guten abend herr paul
ja vielleicht können sie uns direkt
erzählen wie ist die situation zurzeit
bei ihnen im klinikum
der man kann deutlich sagen jetzt die
situation hat deutlich angezogen ich
kann ihnen sagen ich bin die zweite
woche ausnahmen im urlaub bei einer
fortbildung zurück
ich saß da noch im urlaub auf die
tagelange fortbildung um das wissen
aufzufrischen oder gegangen bin haben
wir vereinzelt 121 patienten waren um
die in der patienten reiserückkehrer
sind dass ich zurückgekommen bin
mittlerweile zwei normalen stationen und
wir haben die der patienten auf den
stationen sondern alles noch im
normalbetrieb freue ich mich aber so
deutlich angezogen was wir sehen ist
das muss man wirklich sagen über 90
prozent oder etwas mehr um die
operationen gegen das verstand oder die
nacht bürgen
und wir sind gerade ihre patienten vom
alter her im vergangenen winter waren es
ja hauptsächlich die älteren
da kann ich über beispiele bringen dass
ein bisschen aktuell etwa
26.000 klinik und in die versorgung das
können erfreulich aber das noch in
meiner betrieb managen aber das sind zum
beispiel dabei in die 30 jährige frauen
da bin ich dann zwei frauen die
schwanger sind und sauerstoff benötigen
haben wir haben 80 jährigen patientin
auch in den stationen der beatmet wird
ganz tragischen fall in der letzte woche
an bier zentrum auch direkt wo diese
gelungene eine patientin drahtig jahre
von anhalt übernommen
der leider verstorben ist er zu hause
jetzt
eine schwangere frau und zwei kinder
zurück lässt natürlich extremfälle aber
es sind freundlich und natürlich sagen
dass deutlich mehr die umgesetzten von
einem jungen wer die impfquote noch
nicht so hoch gefühle sonst münchen und
man das ist eine richtige einordnung der
institute zu eineinhalb lernen hatten
wir wären aktuellen dienten schubkarren
115 2 und viele freunde der coop normale
station in 12 vollendet haben wenn nicht
mehr also informiert ist kann man ganz
deutlich sagen
überwiegen die energie nicht gehen in
szene
andreas schreibt uns auf youtube wenn
die auslastung der intensivbetten im
nächsten winter nicht höher ausfällt als
immer im winter dann ist die pandemie
durch über 70% impfquote kommen wir eh
nicht freedom day wäre vernunft was
sagen sie dem
können sie sich schon denken was ich
dazu sage wenn ich ihnen geben sind
beispiele liegen gesagt habe vor augen
von green day haltestellen und ich finde
wir sollten auf sicht fahren und
stufenweise vorgehen und ich auch alles
auf einen schlag wurde im moment auch
noch europaweit etwas zurück hängen
und die frage ist berechtigt schafkopfen
stanton auslöst bin ich vergeben wird
hingegen schwer damit
jetzt auf dauer zu tun haben und
bei den stationen nicht mehr übermäßig
ausgelastet sind daran kann man
natürlich zurückfahren aktuell noch
nicht gegeben
paul ich verdienen gerne eine
persönliche frage stellen also wenn sie
dann menschen sehen die wirklich schwer
schwer an corona erkrankt sind und die
sich eben gegen eine impfung entschieden
hatten wie schwer ist es für sie damit
umzugehen
eine frage die jetzt mag recht haben
diese woche auch schon diese frage
gestellt
manches scheint das ärgert das würde ich
nicht sagen
die meisten leute bei jungen patienten
mit schweren worten auch bei den älteren
sind noch in form aber wir
stellen uns die frage
was man noch machen das amt angeboten
ist so einfach zu erreichen ist ich
glaube was das problem nach für noch ist
das wir bisher gruppen nicht mit dem
angebot aber einigen wenn ich sehe meine
stücke modern zuletzt
wir waren ihnen pro woche fiel einfach
kann es gar nicht gehen
tatsächlich wenn sie mich fragen stimmt
traurig
dass ich sagen würde
der stürmer welche schmerzen bereitet
ihnen das wenn sie sehen dass
deutschland mit der impfquote nicht mehr
so richtig voran kommt dass selbst diese
große infektions woche letzte woche
nicht diesen diesem wust gebracht hat
den man sich erhofft hat
ganz ehrlich mich ja nicht viel erwartet
muss ich sagen weil das was in dieser
impfwoche sozial kondensiert auch mal
angeboten worden ist sind sachen die
schon mehrmals vorfeld gelaufen sind und
die die man bis dato nicht abgeholt hat
wird man damit auch nicht großartig
kriegen ich bin ein bisschen frustriert
dass wir nicht einfach untersuchungen
waren verändert aber die ausrede von
nationalen jagd ja die rausgefunden
haben wo letztendlich die problemkinder
liegen also wer lässt sich nicht impfen
warum ich versuche das auch durch
gespräche herauszufinden was sind die
motivation sich nicht lassen und es ist
ein gemisch aus zum beispiel religiösen
dingen es ist ein gemisch aus ich bin
doch er überzeugt von dem was in den
sozialen medien an mist erzählt wird und
das sind so die dinge da muss man
versuchen einfach gegenzusteuern und
versuchen eben die impf angebote das in
dieses impfen dorthin zu bringen wo
einfach die unentschlossenen leute sind
die einfach noch ein bisschen den
abbrand schubs verbrauchen und ich
glaube da sollte man mehr investieren
und dann könnten wir auch noch ein
bisschen mehr gas geben ja und ein
großes problem finden was ich auch sehe
es gibt ja noch einen impfstoff der
basiert auf den bisher bekannten
techniken viele menschen sind ein
bisschen noch weiterhin zurückhaltend
mit der mrsa oder der vector technik
weil sie sagen das ist mir alles zu neu
das ist mir zu schnell gegangen da kann
jetzt die politik nichts für dass dieser
impfstoff in der zulassung immer noch
fest hängt aber wenn der käme ein
proteine im stoff dann hätten wir meiner
meinung nach auch noch mal einen
gehörigen schub in der in der impfquote
aber das sind alles dinge die muss man
muss man zusehen dass man die in die
hand nimmt und ändert damit wir
vorwärtskommen vielleicht kann sie uns
noch ein paar informationen zu diesem
impfstoff geben der dann hoffentlich
kommen soll
ja das ist ein protein basierte
impfstoff nowaks ist da ist der firma
ist die firma jetzt mal der name des der
substanz im februar oder märz glaube ich
schon eingereicht worden und wenn ich es
richtig mitbekommen habe dann wird jetzt
werden jetzt die finalen daten wohl im
vierten quartal also ab oktober den
zulassungsbehörden zur verfügung
gestellt ich kann natürlich nicht in die
glaskugel schauen wie stellst damit der
zulassung geht aber das ist auch etwas
was sie in gesprächen herausgefunden
habe wenn der kommt dann habe ich von
vielen gehört dann würde ich mich jetzt
auch impfen lassen also insofern habe
ich dann noch ein bisschen hoffnung dass
das nicht erst im nächsten jahr passiert
okay aber eine weile wird zahlt doch
noch dauern und papa jetzt müssen wir
trotzdem auch noch mal an sie die frage
durch den nächsten herbst und den winter
wie bereiten sie sich in der klinik auf
diese jahreszeiten vor
mittlerweile muss man sagen
sagen aber gut vorbereitet wie ihr euch
mit dem schlimmsten hoffen auf das beste
schon zwischen den zweiten oder dritten
werdet ihr einen plan ausgearbeitet wir
haben sozusagen die kennzahlen ab der
auf dem marsch sondern auf der
intensivstation müssen jene und jenen
jene stationen
aufmachen personal schriften im
schlimmsten fall ist aber natürlich
absolut vermeiden muss die optik
kapazität wieder zurückgefahren werden
waren nämlich fast mit schadet sind
betten haben was vor allem das personal
zusätzlich richtung stuttgart
liegt jetzt aber stellt mobile ihm
ziehen sollten wir mal in
folge in der klinik auch eine
bevölkerung zu erreichen und die er nach
dem großen inflation bei den
mitarbeitern wirklich gut mit neuen
influenza das sind sie die nächsten
schritte ein balken
der stürmer ich habe noch eine frage
sie von revo auf youtube wann den
t-zellen tests als genesende nachweis
anerkennt werden anerkannt werden
ich gehe davon aus dass antikörpertest
primär gemeint werden weil t zell
antwort ist natürlich ein sehr
spezifischer testing netz man in der
breiten masse gar nicht als labortest
anbieten kann was angeboten wird sind
der klassische antikörpertest und es gab
mal tatsächlich eine kurze phase wo die
ständige impfkommission
einem antikörper nachweis auch als als
zulassung oder zugelassen hat für den
nachweis einer durchgemachten infektion
das ist aber sehr schnell wieder
verworfen worden in der nächsten version
das problem der antikörper test ist
einfach dass wir schwierigkeiten haben
werden mit einer aussage wenn zum
beispiel die antikörper über die zeit
schon wieder nachgelassen haben ich habe
jetzt ein negativen test kann ich
trotzdem nicht zeigen dass ich früher
positiv gewesen bin und im umgekehrten
fall gut da wäre es möglich die tester
sind inzwischen deutlich ausgereifter
also es wird sicherlich da nochmal
veränderungen geben aber ich rechne
damit nicht zeitnah dass antikörper test
als nachweis für früher durchgemacht
infektionen anerkannt werden
herr paul ich würde ihnen gerne noch
eine letzte frage stellen und nochmal
bezug auf diesen freedom day nehmen
sehen sie das überhaupt dass das
irgendwann bei uns kommt oder sehen sie
eher dass es so step by step bmw
vorangehen sollte
meine meinung ist dass wir das habe ich
vorhin gestundeten herbst und liegt auf
sicht fahren sollten jetzt vorgefahren
aber irgendwann das ist ja ganz klar
muss auch sozusagen wieder die status
qualität einkehren ich persönlich
natürlich fragen ist er im frühling
wenn so zusammen katja es dann wieder
frei wir wissen jetzt haben jetzt schon
mal gesehen der kalten jahreszeit
politische generation gesagt erstrahlen
die studentenzahlen da werden wir
natürlich mehr in die
situation teilweise
abgeplatzt
27.000 ältere patienten mit ihrer mitte
sei noch im fluss politische erfolge war
jetzt nur verläufe das müssen auch noch
denken
noch mal steht ganz klar das wünsche ich
mir auch wünsche ich das nicht und ich
persönlich und sie nicht fragen
nach abklingen dieser virtuelle nach im
winter
dann würde ich diese letzte frage auch
noch mal ein sie gerne weitergeben her
stürmer hätten sie gerne einen freedom
day und wenn ja dann war ja
ich glaube da sind wir beide das ist
dass zum jetzigen zeitpunkt die sowieso
nicht und ich sehe es ganz genauso wir
sollten uns erst mal darum kümmern diese
vierte welle in den griff zu bekommen
die impfquote deutlich zu steigern ich
bin ganz bei ihnen das wären im frühling
sicherlich in der lage sein werden über
die rückkehr zur normalität sehr
intensiv diskutieren zu können wenn ich
sogar umsetzen zu können wir haben ja
heute die nachricht bekommen dass fünf
bis elfjährigen sehr gute
studienergebnisse was die impfung angeht
vorliegen also es geht vorwärts und wir
werden was meine definition zur rückkehr
zur normalität ist also impfung für alle
werden wir denke ich spätestens dieses
nächstes jahr im frühjahr erreichen
damit möchte ich mich bedanken für ihre
einblicke diese geschildert haben und
für ihre einschätzungen und wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend
dankeschön
und auch bei ihnen möchte ich mich
bedanken für ihre fragen und ihre
kommentare und dafür dass sie dabei
waren auch ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und bis bald